ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋
สวัสดีค่ะครูเตรียมสวัสดีค่ะนะเรียน
เรียนวันนี้นะเวรตกใจนิดหน่อยตกใจว่าทำไม
ครูเรียมกับครูเอ๋ใส่เสื้อสีขาว
2 คนไม่ได้โทรศัพท์แล้วบอกเลี้ยง
เยี่ยมเพื่อสีขาไม่ได้พูดนะคะกับเปิดส่ง
กติผู้เรียนจะมีสิทธิ์
อ้าว
ทำไมสีขาวเหมือนกัน
ธรรมดากูเอกจะใส่สี 4 สีน้ำเงินเนาะสี
น้ำเงินสีฟ้านะคะ 2 สีหรอสีน้ำเงินสีฟ้า
สีดำสีดำสีดำแบบนั้นเนี่ยติดเมาส์เนี่ยสี
ดำ
วันนี้มาอุ้ยขาวกับขาวนักเรียนยังมีสีถ้า
พี่โอเค
มีการสร้างขานิดคิดว่าจะนัดไม่แมวไม่เห็น
ละเห็นล่ะ
ไม่เอากี่ตัวคะนี่แม่
e4e ตัว
ตู้
แดงแล้ว 6 ตัวหน้า
ผุเรียงคะก่อนที่เราจะคุยกันวันนี้ครูเอ๋
มีเรื่องลื่นเรื่องรอเรือกับรอลิงสลับกัน
เรื่องเล่านะคะเป็นเรื่องเล่าให้ฟังแต่
ก่อนอื่นเราไปดูวันที่ก่อนดีกว่าค่ะได้
ได้ค่ะวันนี้วันอะไรคะครูเรียมวันนี้วัน
อาทิตย์ค่ะ
วันอาทิตย์นะขาว
เมื่อวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
12 ค่ะเก๋
12 เดือนอะไรคะเดือนมิถุนายน
ปีพตอะไรคะพ.ศ
ปีขอศ.อะไรคะข้อ
2522 ค่ะ
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอนนี้
11:02 ค่ะ
11:02 นะคะก็พูดไป Robot เลยนะ
โอเค
ลบๆมีเรื่องเล่ามีเรื่องเล่าเรื่องนี้นะ
กูตอนตอนครูเอ๋เด็กๆอ่ะชอบมาก
แต่ก็มีเรื่องเล่าเขาบอกว่ามันจะมีมีมี
เป็นเป็นภูเขาเนาะหาคุยวัดภูเขาก่อน
ภูเขาและที่ภูเขาและมีป่า
มีต้นไม้ราคานาอันนี้เป็นคนบาท
คนหมาย
ต้นไม้มากๆนักเรียนเขาเรียกว่าอะไรครับ
คุณเรียมเรียกว่าป่า
ห้าชายเรียกว่าป่า
ที่นี้เนี่ยมันก็จะมีหมู่บ้านนะคะหมู่
บ้าน
เรื่องเนี้ยกูเรียนเป็นเรื่องน่า
อย่านานมานะ
มากนานมาก
น่าจะนานก่อนครู x เกิดเพราะกูกูเองและ
50 กว่าๆ
ไม่มีอาจารย์ 100 ปี 200 ปีสามร้อยปี
สามร้อยปีขึ้นไปเนาะคิดว่านะคะเขาบอกว่า
อย่างนี้ครูเรียมเขาบอกว่ามันมี
มันมีเรื่องเล่าที่เขาพูดกันอ่ะมีคนเขามี
หมู่บ้านตรงนี้กูเห็นหมู่บ้านที่คุยว่า
มั้ยเนี่ยเห็นค่ะเห็นหมู่บ้านเห็นป่าเก็บ
ภูเขาโอเค
กอล์ฟมีคนในหมู่บ้านเนี่ยค่ะคนในหมู่บ้าน
[เพลง]
คนในหมู่บ้านเนี่ยเขาก็คุยกัน
เขาบอกว่ามันมีเมืองอยู่เมืองนึงเมือง
ผมชื่อเมืองลับแล
คนที่หมู่บ้านณัฐเรื่องที่กูไอ้อ่านแต่
เขาเพราะมีเมืองอยู่เมืองชื่อรับแลบอก
แล้วว่ารับรับนี่แปลว่าไกลๆรับแลคือมอง
ไม่เห็นหน้าชาวบ้านคนเดินตัวเมืองลับแล
ทอนเขาก็คุยกันบ่โอ๊ยในป่าเนี่ย
ในป่ามีเมืองลับแล
ได้ประมือกับแหละเนี่ยพระขัดใครเข้าไปก็
ไม่ได้ถ้าเข้าไปแล้วอาจจะออกมาไม่ได้
เมืองน่ากลัวน่ากลัว
เขาก็บอกกันว่าห้ามข้ามเข้าไปในปากนะ
ห้ามเข้าไปเพราะว่าบางคนนั่งบางคนเข้าไป
ปั๊บเพราะเข้าไปเข้าไปอยู่ตรงนี้เข้าไป
และอ่าเอกบอกว่ามันก็จะมี
คุยใส่ถ้าเป็นกลางคืนเนาะถ้าเป็นกันคืน
คุยทำให้เป็นกลางคืนก่อนนะคะนักเรียนสัก
ครู่
ก็เป็นกำลังคืนสีเทาแล้วกันตอนกลางคืนเรา
เข้าป่าไปทำไมคะผู้เหวางคนเข้าไปจับสัตว์
จะกลับไปหาจับจับอะไรสักอย่างนึงนะคะเขา
บอกว่าบัญชีเข้าไปแล้วกูเรียมออกบางคน
เข้ากันในไปจับไก่จับรู้จักอะไร
จับจับไก่ไก่ก็
อ้าก็บอกว่าบางทีน่ะก็จะมีเห็นเป็นควัน
สีเขาค่ะ
ดู
รอบๆตัว
รอบๆตัวแบบนี้
เออ
สมัยก่อนเขาไม่รู้
เขาไม่รู้เขาก็บอกว่าก็ดีข้างนอกนั้นเป็น
นอกจากปกติมันจะร้อนครูเรียมข้างนอกเนี่ย
มีแต่มีแสงอาทิตย์ใช่ไหมคะก็จะร้อน
ร้อนและพอเข้าไปข้างในน่ะมันจะเย็น
ทุเรียนลองคิดดูว่าถ้ากูเรียนอยู่ตรงนี้
ร้อนร้อนมากๆแต่ครูเรียมเดินเข้าไปในป่า
เดินไปแล้วก็มีสีขาวรอบตัวมองไม่เห็น
เพื่อนมองไม่เห็นอะไรเลย
มีแต่สีขาว
กลัวไหม
อยู่ที่ไหนข้าง
ก็บอกอยู่ไหนไม่รู้
น่ากลัวใช่ไหมเขาก็เลยบอกว่าไม่ให้เข้าไป
ที่เมืองนี้เขาไปแล้วเนี่ยมันจะได้กลัว 5
ผู้ชายคนนี้มีอาชีพหาของป่า
ของป่าแต่ก็อย่างเช่นอ้ะเขตเนาะเห็ดหน่อ
ไม้ใช่ไหมคะคุยหน่อไม้นะคะ
อุ้ยก็มาว่าที่ถนนเลยนะ
หน่อไม้
ตรงนี้ค่ะหน่อไม้กินได้นะคะอ่ะคิดต้นไม้
ต้นไม้ก็อาจจะมี
รังผึ้งนะครับเพิ่งก็จะเป็น
เพลงแล้วก็มีน้ำหวาน
น้ำหวานถ้ากินได้วันว่าอาหารนะคะวินนี่
เดอะพูห์ชอบ
ผู้ชายหรือบางทีเขาก็ไปหาหายหายากหาอะไร
ตรงเนี้ย
สำหรับเอามาเอาไปเป็นกินแล้วแข็งแรงนะคะ
เราเรียกว่าอาชีพหาของป่า
[เพลง]
คุยลบอันนี้ก่อนนะคะลบของป่าก่อนอุ้ย -
ผู้ชายไปด้วย
ผู้ชายไม่มีผู้ชายคน
ให้ท้อง
ใช่ค่ะเขาก็ไปหาของป่าก็ไปอยู่แต่นี่ก็
ดื่มเงียบๆตัวเองหมายถึงปากแล้วเนี่ยที่
น่ากลัวเหรอ
คือเขาว่ามันคุ้นเหลี่ยมเค้าเดินเข้าป่า
อื่นแล้วเขาก็หลงหลงหลงเขาก็เคยได้ยินนะ
แต่มันบอกในป่ามีเมืองลับแล
เมืองที่มีผู้หญิงเดินออกมาแล้วก็หายเข้า
ไปไม่รู้ไปที่ไหนหลายๆคนก็กลัวผู้ชายคน
นี้ก็ไปหาของป่าแล้วไม่แน่ใจว่าเขามาจาก
หมู่บ้านอื่นหรือยังไงหมายถึงไม่ได้อยู่
ใกล้ๆที่นี่แล้วเขาไม่รู้หรืออะไรไม่ทราบ
แต่เขาอ่ะอ่ะก็หาจนเข้าไปในเมืองที่มีมี
ความแล้วเขามองเห็นต้นมาเปล่าคะมันมีควัน
เยอะขนาดนี้ก็เห็นนเห็นในน้อยๆค่ะเป็นแบบ
และรับรอบใช่ไหมว่าจะมีสีขาวๆเขาก็อะไร
อยู่ที่ไหนเนี่ย
ตื่นเต้นตกใจแล้วนะคะเขาก็กลัวเขาก็เวลา
กลัวเนี่ยผู้ชายอ่ะก็ไม่ร้องผู้ชายคนนี้
ก็สติดีมากก็เงียบ
มากตกใจแล้วก็ถ้าเงียบนะคะไม่ร้องอะไร
แล้วเขาก็เห็นอันนี้ก็ครูเรียมเค้าเคย
เห็นผู้หญิง
ผู้หญิงแต่งตัวแบบนี้
บางคนใส่ผ้า
จะ
บางคนก็แล้วก็มีภาพ
ไม่สบายนิดหน่อย
ผู้หญิงนะคะมีผู้หญิงมาคุยว่าง่ายๆแล้ว
กันเราพูดกันกับผู้หญิงผู้หญิงผู้หญิงไม่
มีผู้ชายออกมาเลยเหรอคะตัวเองไม่มีค่ะมี
แต่ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงสวย
สปี่หน้าคนฟอกประมาณเนี้ยประมาณ 4  5 คน
ผู้หญิงล่ะครูเรียนเขาบอกมีผู้หญิงเดิน
ออกมา
เราก็พูดชายก็ได้แอบมาดูเฮ้ยทำไมผู้หญิง
อยู่ในป่า
ค่าผ้าครูเรียมเป็นผู้ชายถ้าคุยในเป็นผู้
ชายนะแล้วก็เห็นป่ามีควันเขาขาวๆมีมีหมอก
ฤษฎ์หมอกควันแบบสีเข้า
ขาวไปหมดมองไม่เห็นข้างในตรงทางเดินนะมอง
ไม่เห็นข้างในนะแล้วก็เห็นผู้หญิงเดินออก
มาคือมันน่ากลัวคือเป็นอ้าหาก็บอกว่า
โอ้โหไม้ไม่มีบ้านคนเงียบอายุ you ก็มี
ผู้หญิงเดินออกมาเอ่อผู้เรียนจะไป Hello
สวัสดีไว้ไม่ค่ะ
หรือเปล่าใช่ไหม
แล้วก็แอบดู
ค่ะ
ผู้ชายคนนี้ก็เหมือนกูเรียมคือแอบดูดูผู้
หญิงไปไหนก็พูดถ้ามีก็ในมือน่ะเขามีใบไม้
ก็มีเขามีใบมาไม้
ใบไม้นะคนละ 1 ใบ
จะเป็นใบไม้ที่ไม่เหมือนที่นี่นะคะเป็นใบ
ไม้ที่ไม่เหมือนนี่และทุกคนก็เอาใบไม้ไป
ซ่อนยังคนนี้เอาใบตรงนี้นี่ก้อนหินโอเค
ไม่ก่อนหีบ
ตอนหินเป็นคนนี้ก็เอาใบไม้นะไว้ใต้ก้อน
หินคนนี้ก็ไว้ตรงนี้
มีใบไม้
วันนี้ก็ไว้ตรงนี้
คนนี้ก็ไว้ตรงนี้วันนี้ก็ไว้ตรงนี้มีใบ
ไม้คนละ 1 ใบแล้วเขาก็เอาไปซ่อนเอาไว้คือ
มีอะไรสมมติว่ามีอันนี้แล้วกันแล้วก็เอา
ใบไม้อ่ะไปไม้ไว้ข้างใต้
ใต้ก้อนหินก้อนหินโอ๊ยตายตอนหินแล้วทั้ง
หมดก็เดินเข้าออกไปที่หมู่บ้านคือผู้ชาย
คนนี้หลงใช่ไหมกูเรียมทางเป็นคู๋นะเอก
เจริญตื่น
กลับ
นะแต่ผู้ชายคืนนี้ไม่กลับเลียมอ่ะก็เห็น
ใช่มะผู้ชายก็คิดได้เมืองรับแล้วแอร์
[เพลง]
ก็
ไม่รู้ตดูแล้วก็ต้องไปด้วยกันใช่ไหมคะผู้
ชายก็คิดเลยอยากรู้อยากเห็น
งั้นแล้วพอผู้หญิงทั้งหมดออกไปอ่ะผู้หญิง
ไม่อยู่ละไม่อยู่คุยลบคุยลบผู้หญิงกับ
ผู้หญิงออกไปเต้น
ผู้หญิงไปหมดละเขาทำยังไงอ่ะ
ผู้ชายคนนี้ค่ะผู้ชายคนนี้เขาก็
มาตรงนี้
แล้วก็เอาใบไม้
หนึ่งใบ
มีอยู่คนหนึ่งที่ซ่อนไว้ใต้ก้อนหินคน
เดียวจะเอาไปไหมอันเนี้ยแล้วเขาก็ขึ้น
ขึ้นไปบนต้นไม้แล้วก็รออยู่บนต้นไม้
รออยู่บนต้นไม้รอ
ผู้สาวผู้เองเขารอผู้หญิงกลับมา
เขาก็นั่งรอกูเรียนรอนานเลยรอจนผู้หญิง
ผู้หญิงทั้ง 5 คนน่ะที่ไปซื้อของน่ะ
ผู้หญิงทั้งทั้งโทษเนี่ย
กลับมาเขาก็เห็นผู้หญิงน่ะไปเปิดดิบใบไม้
ของตัวเองนะคะอีกคนเนี่ยครับไปหยิบไปหมาย
ที่อยู่เนี้ยแล้วก็เดินเข้าไปก็เลยแล้วก็
หายเข้าไปเลย 4 คน
คนทำไมเข้าไป 4 คนน่ะกูอีกคนสุดท้ายมาช้า
อ่าก็มี
คำสุดท้ายก็สวย
สวยทุกคนคนนี้ที่คุยว่าตอนแรกสวยๆ
คนสุดท้ายก็มาแล้วก็อาทิก้อนหินแล้วก็
ใบไม้หายไปไหนใบไม้ข้อเราผู้หญิงไหมหาหา
ใบไม้ไม่เจอ
ก็หาไม่เจอแป๊บเนี่ยกูเรียมผู้หญิงเขาก็
ตกใจแล้วก็ร้องไห้ใหญ่เลย
ไม่มาขายแล้วทำยังไงราคาที่นี้
กูเรียนสงสัยไว้อ่ะทำไมต้องร้องไห้ใบไม้
หายก็เดินกลับบ้านไปใช่ไหมมี
ก็เดินกลับบ้านไปไงใบไม้ก็หาหา
ใบไหมอันใหม่อีกอันนึงก็ได้
ให้เราก็คิดแบบนี้มีผู้ชายก็ทำไมผู้หญิง
ร้องไห้แล้วผู้หญิงก็พูดว่าจะกลับบ้านยัง
ไงไม่มีใบไม้เข้าบ้านไม่ได้ไม่มีใบไม้
อันเนี้ยเข้าหมู่บ้านไม่ได้
แล้วผู้หญิงก็ร้องไห้มากๆเพื่อนก็ไปหมด
แล้วใช่ไหมคะคนนี้ซื้อซื้อของนานซื้อของ
เยอะ
ชนะมีมีของเยอะมีของมีของเยอะก็เลยร้อง
ไห้ผู้ชายก็สงสารค่ะครูเรียมผู้ชายก็ลงมา
จากต้นไม้
ถ้าคุณเรียนเป็นผู้หญิงใช่ไหมผู้ชายก็บอก
อ้ะ
ใบไม้อยู่ที่เราดีใจเลยคะ
ตกใจสิ
แต่ก็ดีใจอยู่ดีถ้างั้นอยากได้ใบไม้ไหม
อยากได้ไหมอยากได้
อยากได้หรออยากได้นะต้องให้เราเข้าไปด้วย
ถ้าจะเอาใบไม้
ราวต้องเข้าไปด้วยกันได้ไหม
ได้ไหมคะ
คุณลืมคิดนาน
ไหมล่ะถ้าไม่มีใบไม้นอกเข้าไปในบ้านไม่
ได้ไงก็ต้องใช่
ใช่ไหมคะใช่ใช่ๆผู้หญิงก็คิดนานวันครู
เรียมแล้วก็ก็บอกว่าได้
คือคือไม่มีทางเลือกอยากจะกลับบ้านก็ต้อง
มีใบไม้ถ้าไม่ให้ผู้ชายไปด้วยก็ไม่ได้ใบ
มายก็กลับบ้านก็ได้นะครับ
หรือว่าจะถ่ายก็อยากรู้แล้วก็ปล่อยหนูไม่
ได้
แล้ว
วิ่งไม่ได้แข็งแรงมาก
เสร็จแล้วเนี่ยผู้ชายกับผู้หญิงก็เดินผู้
หญิงไม่ได้อยากพาไปแต่จำใจก็พาเข้าไปผู้
ชายก็ช่วยถือของแล้วก็เข้าไป
ก็เดินเข้าไปในหมู่บ้าน
เข้าไปเพราะเข้าไปแล้วเนี่ยผู้ชายก็เห็น
มันเป็นเหมือนกับมี Two เขารอบๆโคเรียม
รับพอเข้าไปปุ๊บเนี่ยเพราะก็เห็นมีบ้านคน
บ้านคนเยอะเลย
บ้านคน
ทุกคนในหมู่บ้านก็มีคนเป็นผู้หญิงดีๆเธอ
เป็นผู้หญิง
ผู้หญิงหมดเลยเฮ้ยไม่มีผู้ชายคนเดียวก็
ไม่มีไม่มีก็เขาก็เลยไปที่นี่ค่ะไปที่
บ้านของผู้หญิง
ทำไมคะทำไมถึงมีแต่ผู้หญิงค่ะกูเองและน่ะ
สิที่ไม่ทำไมนักเรียนเขาก็ไปที่บ้านมีอะ
ตัวนี้มีหลังคาด้วยและกันอะหลังคาก็ไปที่
บ้านนี้ที่บ้านบ้านผู้หญิงอ่ะผู้หญิงสวย
นะคะเขาก็มาทุกคนก็ทำไมมีผู้ชายผู้ชายอก
ผู้ชายก็ตกใจผู้หญิงนี่บอกว่ากับตกใจเขา
ก็เลยพาไปที่บ้านก็ที่นี่ก็จะมีคุณแม่คุณ
แม่ของผู้หญิงนะคะเขาก็ผ่านมีผู้ชายก็เลย
ถามเหมือนครูเรียมถามนั่นแหละทำไมไม่มี
ผู้ชายทำไมมีแต่ผู้หญิง
คุณแม่ไม่ตอบบ้านผู้หญิงก็
ออกมาขอที่บ้านเนี้ยเป็นหมู่บ้านที่ห้าม
โกหก
คนที่หมู่บ้านเก๋ต้องมีศีลค่าข้อ 5 ข้อ
เราเรียกว่ารักษาศีลคือ 155 มข้าข้า
ไม่ได้
2 ห้ามขโมย
จะไม่ไปเห็นเห็นอะไรล่ะเห็นเงินกูยังไม่
มีเงินแต่ไม่อาจเห็นแหวนแล้วกันน่ะเห็น
แหวนนี่แหวนเห็นแหวนคนอื่นสวยขโมย
ขโมยไม่ได้อ่ะคะแล้วก็
ห้ามอาจเจ้าชู้
เห็นผู้หญิงสวยแล้วก็ไปจับผู้หญิงอะไร
อย่างเงี้ยไม่ได้หรือว่ามีภรรยามากกว่า 1
คนไม่ได้
นะแล้วก็ห้ามห้ามดื่ม
แอลกอฮอล์นาๆๆ
ว่าห้ามโกหกห้ามโกหก 5 อย่างคือแท็กคุณ
อื่นคนดีอยู่ที่นี่ได้อยู่ที่นี่ได้แม่
ผู้หญิงก็ถามผู้ชายเป็นคนดีไหมผู้ชายบ่ก็
ผมไม่ฆ่าผมเก็บเห็ดเก็บเห็ดด้วย
เก็บเห็ดผมไม่
ฮ่าๆๆผมไม่เคยแต่งงานเออผม
ก็ยังไม่แต่งงานผมไม่โกหกผมไม่ดื่มผู้ชาย
ผู้ตรงผู้ชายไม่โกหกจริงๆเป็นคนดีผู้ชาย
คนนี้เป็นคนดีมากๆ
ก็คิดว่าจริงๆคนดีวะ
ใช่คุณแม่ก็บอกว่าคุณแม่กับผู้หญิงก็บอก
ว่าที่หมู่บ้านนี้ให้เพิ่มพระจริงๆนะ
โกหกเนี่ยไม่ได้เลยนะโดยเฉพาะโกหกโกหก
เนี่ยห้ามห้าม 100% เพราะว่าถ้าโกหก 100%
เลยนะห้าม
เขาก็ได้บอกว่าที่ไม่มีผู้ชาย
เพราะผู้ชายชอบ
โกหกอ๋อ
ๆคือก็เลยมีกับผู้หญิงผู้หญิงเฮ้ยเฮ้ยผู้
ชายเลยผู้ชายหนึ่งคนก็ไม่มีเลย
ใช่เพราะถ้าผู้ชายมาแล้วผู้ชายเริ่มโกหก
ต้องออกไป
ผู้ชายโกหกไม่โกหกทุกคนเชื่อบอกว่าผู้ชาย
ไม่โกหกโม้เพิ่งเจอผู้ชายดี
ทำยังไงคะผู้ชายดี
แต่งงานสิคะ
ก็แต่งงานนะคะผู้หญิงกับผู้ชายก็แต่งงาน
อยู่ที่หมู่บ้านนี้เค้าก็เป็นผู้ชายดี
จริงๆไม่โกหกเถอะผู้หญิงคนนี้
ท้อง
ค่ะ
ว่าท้องแล้วก็คลอดลูก
[เพลง]
อุดลูกผู้หญิงหรือผู้ชายคะเนี่ย
รูปผู้ชายนะ
แม่เกศก็จะไม่ปิดลูกผู้ชายอ่าลูกผู้ชาย
อนาคตลูกคงต้องออกจากหมู่บ้านไม่รู้
ทำไมคราฟข้อบ้านเลยอยู่ได้อยู่ได้เพราะ
เป็นคนไม่โกหกไงก็อยู่ที่นี้เนี่ย
ปรากฏว่าเขาก็ก็อยู่พอเลี้ยงลูกใช่ไหมคะ
บางวันบางวันภรรยาเลี้ยงลูกสามีไปทำงาน
บางวันสามีไปทำงานภรรยาเลี้ยงลูกบางวัน
ภรรยาไปทำงานสามีมีผู้ชายคนเนี้ยเขาก็
เรียนลูกหากอะมีความสุขดีมากครูเรียมไม่
มีปัญหาเลยจนกระทั่งวันนึงว่าลูกลูกโตนะ
ลูกลูกไม่ใช่เล็กๆอ่ะลูกโตละ
1-2 ขวบยังไม่ได้พูดได้มากๆก็ยังแน่วัน
นั้นน่ะรู้จักแต่ก็ทำงานรอบๆบ้านทำงาน
แล้วก็เหนื่อย
ภรรยาก็ไปทำงานนะคะอาจจะไปในภูเขาไปทำงาน
นะคะลูกก็ได้
เสือ
ร้องไห้จะหาแม่แต่แม่น่ะกลับช้าห้าแม่นะ
กลับช้าพูดถึงอะเวลาลูกร้องแม่
เราก็จะโอ้วใช่ไหมเวลาเลี้ยงลูกจะโอมไม่
ร้องไม่ร้องไม่ร้องร้องอะแล้วร้านอาจจะ
บอกเดี๋ยวเดี๋ยวเขาว่าเดี๋ยวเดียวแม่กลับ
มา
รอหน่อยอันนี้พูดตลกเดี๋ยวแม่จะกลับมาลูก
นะจริงๆแบบนี้ร้องไห้คิดถึงแม่เขาก็ดี
เดี๋ยวแม่กลับมารอเธอมารอลูกก็จะหยุดร้อง
ไห้ไม่ร้องไห้แต่วันนี้
บอกว่าเดี๋ยวแม่กลับมาลูกก็ยัง
ร้องไห้สามีก็ไม่รู้ลูกเป็นอะไรสามีก็เลย
แบบแม่มาแล้วแม่มาแล้วหรอ
คุณแม่มาแล้ว
อาทิตย์เขาพูดแม่มาเลยไม่มายังยังทำงาน
อยู่
ยังทำงานอยู่นี่แม่ยายน่ะแม่ยายคนนี้คน
นี้แม่ยายวันนี้สามีภรรยาแม่ยายได้ยินก็
ตกใจแล้วบอกแม่มาแล้วแต่ว่าภรรยายังทำงาน
ยังไม่มาแต่ที่น่าตกใจคือทุกคนในหมู่บ้าน
รู้มีคนโกหกมีคนโกหก
อะไรหนู
เขาทำยังไงคะเพื่อในหนังสือที่ครูเอกให้
อ่านนะเพราะเขาบอกว่าพอผู้ชายคนนี้โกหก
ปั๊ปเนี่ยในหมู่บ้านมันจะมีเสียงคือ
เหมือนสั่นน่ะเอาเหมือนที่ใช่ไหมแต่ว่าคน
ที่ก็ไม่ได้ยินผู้ชายพูดใช่ไหมไม่ได้ยิน
ไม่ได้ยินผู้ชายพูดแบบเหมือนกับมันมี
เสียงแบบ
เราก็ฟ้าห้องน้ำมีพระอาทิตย์ใช่ไหมคะใช่
ตอนนั้นจริงๆก็เป็นเวลาโปรเพลงประมาณสิริ
17:00 นน่ะแล้วก็กลายเป็นว่ามันจะมีเมฆ
มีมีเมฆสีดำๆ
มันก็มึงคือมีสิ่งผิดปกติในหมู่บ้านน่ะ
ที่ทำให้รูปคนรู้ว่ามีคนโกหก
เลิกทำยังไงคะพูดเอ๋เพราะว่าในหมู่บ้าน
เขาบอกว่าใครที่โกหกนะก็จะถูกไล่ออกไปจาก
หมู่บ้านเราผู้ชายคนนี้ค่ะ
ผู้ชายก็ไม่ได้คิดว่าโกหกหรือทุกวันพูด
ว่าเดี๋ยวแม่จะกลับมาอันนี้ไม่โกหก
แต่วันนี้พวกแม่กลับมาแล้วแต่แม่ยังไม่
กลับมาอันนี้โกหกผู้ชายก็ต้องให้ออกโดน
ออกจากหมู่บ้านค่ะคู่เรียม
ว่าโอเคพญาก็เสียใจแต่ก็ต้องออกไป
ผู้ชายภรรยาก็เลยมีอันนี้ให้เวลาจะออกไป
ภรรยาเขาก็มีมีใช่อ่ะพญาก็มียามก็มีขมิ้น
อ่ะมีขมิ้นน่ะเอาขมิ้นน่ะใส่อันนี้คือ
ขมิ้นผงจะเอาแบบนี้เอาไอ้ในนามให้สามี
เยอะเลยแล้วก็มีข้าวมีอาหาร
แล้วก็บอกสามีมีไม่ได้น่าโกหกเลยอันนี้
ข้าวนะเอาไปกินระหว่างเดินหัวหน้าเดินไป
แล้วก็บอกสามีว่าเดินไปทางนี้นะ
แล้วห้ามขันกลับมา
ต้องเดินไปเลยห้ามหันหลังกลับมาไม่ได้
เขาก็เดินออกไปออกไป
ไปกินข้าวก็แอบดูอ่ะนะไปก็ไม่มีอะไรมีแต่
สีขาว
เพราะเขาเดินไปเดินไปเขาก็รู้สึกยามหนัก
หนักหนักหนักเขาเหนื่อยไงเขาก็ได้เอา
ขมิ้นน่ะหยิบขมิ้นแหละทิ้งทิ้ง
ออกมาจนมาถึง
[เพลง]
อยู่มาถึงหมู่บ้านชาย
ก็ออกมาข้อหาที่นี่เขาก็เดินออกไปเดินออก
มาจนถึงที่นี่
คนเห็น
ไปนะแต่ถ้านานวาดไปไหนมาเขาก็บอกอ๋อเขานะ
เข้าไปอยู่ในเมืองลับแล
แต่งานแล้วฉันนาคโกหกนิดเดียวต้องโดนออก
มา
วันนี้นะคะเขาก็บอกเนี่ยภรรยาเนี่ยเอาคอม
มิ่นมาให้ไม่รู้เอามาทำไมให้เยอะหนักฉัน
ก็เลยทิ้งแหละเหลือ 1 อันแล้วก็รู้ว่าใน
ย่ามแล้วก็หยิบขมิ้นขึ้นมาค่ะมันกลายเป็น
ท้องคูณเลี้ยง
[เพลง]
คำว่าเขาเอาทิ้งทิ้งไปที่เยอะเลยแค่ 1
เดือนเดียว
ก็
ชวนเขาก็วิ่งกลับไปวิ่งกลับไปที่เขาทิ้ง
ต้องวิ่งกลับไปเก็บ
เจอ
ไอ้ที่ทิ้งเนี่ยมันกลายเป็นต้นไม้ไปแล้ว
ค่ะมันกลายเป็นต้นขมิ้นต้นขมิ้น
มันไม่ใช่ทองแล้วอยู่ในย่ามคือทองมาอยู่
ในยามคือทองผู้ชายก็เสียดายมาก
ผู้ชายไม่แข็งแรงโกหก
ไม่ทนนะคะเรื่องนี้นะในเมืองลับแลนะฮะก็
เป็นเรื่องเล่าคุณเองก็
เวลาฟังคุณพ่อก็บอกว่าเนี่ยอะไรจะหนักเรา
ก็ต้องอดทนเราก็ห้ามโกหกนะโกหกไม่ดีคุณ
เป็นใครครับคุณเลี้ยง
[เพลง]
เอกก็กำลังสงสัยว่าเห้ยจริงเหรออันนี้
ชื่อเมืองลับแลแต่คู่เอกก็ยังมีความรู้
สึกมันต้องมีจริงที่แบบเป็นแบบเนี้ยว่า
ฝันตั้งแต่เด็กก็เลยเชื่อ
รู้แล้วว่าทำอันนี้แบบพ่อเรื่องนี้
เออโอเคโอเควันนี้ก็หมดเวลาแล้วนะคะถ้า
อยากฟังเรื่องลึกลับสนุกๆนะคะเกี่ยวกับ
ความเชื่อจริงไม่จริงไม่รู้แบบเนี้ยนัก
เรียน 9 อย่าลืมอะไรคะกดไลค์กดแชร์กดไลค์
ให้เรานะคะเราจะได้มาเล่าให้ฟังอีกใช่ค่ะ
Subscribe ด้วยใช่ต้องเจอกันคลิปหน้า
แล้วค่ะคุณพี่วันนี้ต้องลาไปก่อนบ๊ายบาย
ค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนมากอันนี้ภาย